et avec Léa Salamé nous recevons ce
matin dans le grand entretien le
président du shift projet ingénieur
professeur à l'École des Mines Paris
question-réaction 01 45 24 7000 et sur
l'application de France Inter Jean-Marc
Jancovici bonjour bonjour et bienvenue à
ce micro une question générale pour
commencer depuis le début de la guerre
en Ukraine on n'aura jamais autant parlé
d'énergie de notre dépendance de notre
souveraineté de la sobriété nécessaire
dans nos manières de la consommer bref
de tous ces thèmes dont vous avez
longtemps déploré l'absence dans le
débat public avez-vous l'impression
Jean-Marc Jancovici il y a eu ces
derniers mois une bascule une prise de
conscience à la fois chez les dirigeants
dans les médias et chez nous aussi les
citoyens alors la réponse est
globalement Oui au niveau des citoyens
la prise de conscience elle s'est fait
tout bêtement par les prix on a quand
même vu un certain nombre de gens réagir
la facture d'électricité leur facture de
gaz etc et dans la sphère dirigeante il
y a eu également une forme de prise de
conscience à la fois par les prix et
puis aussi par la géopolitique on va
dire on a on a la question de la
sécurité d'approvisionnement est revenu
sur le devant de la scène donc
incontestablement la réponse est oui on
voit des débats émerger qui aurait dû
émerger avant par exemple sur la
structure du marché européen de
l'électricité par exemple etc donc oui
il s'est passé des choses
je sais pas si les citoyens se sont
emparés mais le fait est que le sujet
est présent de manière croissante enfin
où il est plus présent qu'avant dans un
certain nombre de cervelles oui alors le
sujet est présent vous le dites
incontestablement mais est-ce que les
faits suivent la question que je vous
pose c'est elle est basée sur le rapport
annuel de l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie qui a été publié la semaine
dernière et qui était contrastée c'est à
dire que d'un côté il nous apprenait que
le montant des pensées pour les énergies
renouvelables dont le monde n'avait
jamais été aussi important il avait
augmenté de 24% en deux ans mais aussi
dans le même rapport on apprenait que
les dépenses pour les énergies fossiles
le pétrole le gaz le charbon avait aussi
augmenté de 15% en deux ans qu'est-ce
que vous retenez vous de ce rapport sur
sur la manière sur le comportement au
fond de leur pour être très franche je
l'ai pas lu par ailleurs c'est un
panorama mondial qui est évoqué et là à
votre micro on parle quand même plutôt
de ce qu'il y a dans la cervelle des
Français donc voilà il faut il faut
faire attention aux deux en ce qui
concerne le
sujet énergétique en fait il faut pas se
focaliser juste sur la question de la
production électrique les énergies
renouvelables aujourd'hui qui se
développent fortement dans le monde
c'est l'éolien et le solaire donc c'est
la partie électrique ça n'est qu'une
partie de l'énergie qu'on utilise la
mondialisation par exemple qui a
totalement bouleversé la vie des gens
sur les dernières décennies c'est pas dû
essentiellement à l'électricité c'est du
essentiellement au pétrole à la
mondialisation c'est des camions et des
bateaux si on n'avait pas les portes
conteneurs pas les minéraliers et pas
les camions il y aura pas de
mondialisation et c'est pas dû à
l'électricité donc
quand on regarde globalement il y a eu
le choc du covid mais quand au delà
covid mais quand on quand on regarde
globalement ceux qui se passe en
tendance sur les dernières décennies non
ça baisse pas par ailleurs sur les deux
dernières années il y a un tout petit il
faudrait faire la part des choses au
niveau du montant des investissements il
y a eu un petit effet inflation parce
que comme les cobaudies et en
particulier
n'importe quoi y compris les éoliennes
et les panneaux solaires se sont remis à
côté un peu plus cher qu'avant il
faudrait corriger de l'effet de l'effet
prix cela étant il y a une vraie
tendance c'est très clair mais quand on
regarde la part des énergies décarbonées
dans l'énergie qu'on utilise globalement
ou les machines plus exactement parce
que c'est pas nous qui buvons le pétrole
utilisent dans le monde
on a tendance à oublier quand on dit on
consomme de l'énergie en fait non on
utilise des machines
là la part des énergies des carbonées
n'augmente que très doucement dans le
monde précisément parce que les énergies
fossiles sur les 20 dernières années ont
aussi fortement augmenté
de ce travail c'est qu'il a mis des
chiffres un peu partout et qu'il a mis
des chiffres sur des choses qui sont
assez précises donc le plan d'ensemble
il est il est assez précis on va dire ce
qui manque encore dans ce travail mais
bon c'est pas lui faire injure c'est les
mesures opérationnelles qui vont
permettre effectivement de faire en
sorte que tous les objectifs et tous les
souhaits entre qui sont dans ce document
là deviennent une réalité et en ce qui
manquerait par exemple comme mesure que
dans ce plan-là d'accompagnement alors
je vais donner un exemple dans le
bâtiment
le document précise que il faudrait
mettre 200 000 personnes de plus dans la
rénovation du bâtiment bon bah les 200
000 personnes il faut les trouver ça
veut dire que il faut que à ce micro par
exemple régulièrement il y a des gens
qui disent allez donc travailler dans
l'artisanat du bâtiment c'est super vous
allez faire des choses qui sont utiles
pour le payer etc je sais pas si c'est
fait ou pas fait il faut que les gens
aient envie d'y aller il faut que voilà
donc ça c'est pas il suffit pas d'un
claquement de doigts donc là il y a un
objectif on a mis un chiffre il en
faudrait tant ça veut pas dire que
demain matin ça sera fait on peut
prendre un autre exemple
les transports
nous adorons discuter d'avion
qui arrive mais si vous voulez
et bien il y a également dans ce
document un objectif de moins d'avion
pour une partie des gens qui partent en
vacances bon voilà donc là la question
reste ouverte qui est comment on fait
est-ce qu'on monte et ben est-ce qu'on
monte le prix des billets ce qu'on met
des quotas l'aéroport de people en
Hollande enfin au Pays-Bas a essayé
avant que Air France KLM ne lui fasse un
procès pour lui faire faire machine
arrière de diminuer alors c'est pas pour
des raisons de CO2 c'était pour des
raisons de saturation et de bruit mais
peu importe il y avait quand même un
effet CO2 intéressant derrière à essayer
de diminuer le nombre de créneaux de
décollage bon ben ça c'est une
possibilité aussi c'est pas c'est pas un
instrument pris là c'est un instrument
volume et puis vous aviez proposé la
dernière fois je vous avais posé la
question et votre réponse est devenue
absolument virale je crois que elle est
encore postée tout le temps c'est cette
idée qu'il faudrait un de vous aviez dit
je sais plus 4 alors depuis j'ai fait le
calcul alors attendez je vais dire de 4
ou 5 vols dans une ville où chacun
d'entre nous on aurait le droit à quatre
ou cinq vols et voilà comment on lui
très vraiment contre le réchauffement
climatique ça avait fait réagir de tout
côté est-ce que vous maintenez cela ou
est-ce que vous avez évolué non depuis
j'ai fait les calculs c'est à peu près
le bonheur de grandeur mais il faut bien
comprendre que mon père qui était
pourtant une catégorie
socioprofessionnelle supérieure
puisqu'il était prof d'université quand
il est allé aux États-Unis dans les
années 50 pour faire un postdock il est
allé en bateau donc l'idée que même on
puisse prendre quatre vols en avion dans
une vie
il y a un gros demi-siècle ça n'existait
pas je veux dire pour la population dans
son ensemble donc ce truc qui parait
aujourd'hui inconcevable restrictif
malthusien triste cirque casse-bonbon et
j'en passe à une partie des gens qui
réagissent il faut bien que ils se
rendent compte que c'est quelque chose
qui est extrêmement récent
qui partira avec le pétrole parce que
quand on regarde les alternatives
techniques au pétrole dans l'aviation de
toute façon une fois qu'il y aura plus
de pétrole il y aura pas de quoi assurer
quatre vols dans une vie par terrien il
y aura pas oui
[Musique]
et je maintiens qu'il est urgent
d'organiser notre avenir économique en
fonction de ça quand vous regardez par
exemple l'empreinte carbone de Paris un
tiers c'est des vols c'est de l'avion
regardez l'économie parisienne vous avez
une bonne partie de l'économie
parisienne qui repose sur le transport
aérien que ce soit des sièges sociaux de
multinationales du tourisme de les gens
au château de Versailles etc mais il
faut penser un avenir avec moins de ça
pardon de vous apporter la contradiction
mais ça sert aussi à ça de vous
interroger quand vous voyez le
comportement des jeunes voyez on dit que
les jeunes ils se mobilisent pour
l'environnement et tout ça et bien
aujourd'hui qui prend le plus l'avion
alors apporter aux tranches rapportées à
la classe d'âge c'est justement les
jeunes puisque les deux premiers les
deux premiers consommateurs d'avion pour
100000 personnes c'est d'abord
les 24 35 ans non pas dans les 25 34 ans
pas je voulais mettre et ensuite
derrière c'est les 15 24 ans comment on
change les mentalités si c'est même pas
votre père c'est c'est les jeunes qui
veulent continuer à prendre l'avion
alors ils veulent continuer à prendre
l'avion une partie d'entre eux
absolument mais nous vivons dans une
collectivité donc après il faut faire
des compromis une des choses que les
jeunes peuvent très bien faire parce que
quand je dis 4 volts dans une vie c'est
pas 0 on pourrait très bien instaurer un
système dans lequel quand on est jeune
on a deux des quatre vols pour aller
découvrir le monde et puis ensuite quand
on est plus vieux ben on part en
vacances en Corrèze qui est un très beau
département où on part en vacances dans
les Vosges ou on part en vacances en
Corse même où on peut aller en bateau
donc ranger c'est fini quoi on reste on
reste chez soi on y va en train moi il
m'est arrivé parce que j'avais le temps
d'aller en train au Maroc vidéo et voilà
il faut quand même traverser Gibraltar
en bateau mais où on peut aller en train
en Suède vous voyez donc on est quand
même pas qu'on peut même aller en train
à Vladivostok donc on n'est pas
complètement coincé il faut retrouver le
temps de la du voyage qui est un voyage
long et en fait quand le voyage est long
le voyage lui-même est une découverte
quand vous quand vous prenez l'avion en
gros vous passez d'un aéroport urbain un
autre aéroport urbain le dépaysement il
est pas monstrueux quoi mais vous avez
raison il faut avoir le temps tout le
monde n'a pas le temps alors il faut le
il faut l'organiser c'est à dire qu'on
peut très bien l'organiser tout ça alors
on voulait aussi votre avis sur le
rapport pisanima fouze consacré au
financement de la transition écologique
rapport qui préconise à la fois un
recours à cru à l'endettement de 10
points de PIB d'ici à 2030 couplé à un
impôt exceptionnel sur le patrimoine
financier des 10% des contribuables les
plus aisés ce qui rapporterait 5
milliards d'euros par an une sorte
d'isfaire c'est comme ça qu'il a été
baptisé instantanément qu'en pensez-vous
Jean-Marc jancovic ces propositions
elles sont convergentes avec les
résultats d'un article qui est paru dans
une revue technique qui s'appelle
ecological économique il y a quelques
semaines moi je ne sais plus et qui
about à des résultats qui étaient très
voisins c'est à dire que les auteurs
disaient si on veut faire la transition
écologique pour de vrai il faut doubler
la part de l'économie qui va dans les
investissements c'est en fait il faut
refaire des infrastructures des biens
durables c'est les trains c'est les
voitures électriques etc alors eux ne
parlaient pas du financement de ce truc
là mais c'est convergent il faut mettre
tout le monde au travail voilà et par
ailleurs il y aura une baisse de la
consommation et de l'inflation d'accord
donc Pisani il dit des choses qui sont
assez voisines dans les deux cas de
figure les gens continuent à voir de la
croissance du PIB mais en fait c'est une
croissance qui ne se matérialise pas en
croissance de la consommation les gens
n'ont pas plus de mètres carrés et ils
ont pas plus de pistolet à eau à Noël et
c'est à mon avis assez cohérent avec la
façon dont il faut s'attaquer aux
problèmes c'est à dire qu'il va falloir
refaire des infrastructures quand on
refait des infrastructures on les
consomme pas plus pour autant par contre
on y consacre une partie de nos moyens
une partie de la force de travail etc
moi ce que je trouve très intéressant
dans le rapport pisanimafus c'est que il
vient d'une personne qui est très proche
du pouvoir en place qu'on peut pas
supposer qu'on peut pas pardon soupçonné
d'être un gauchiste révolutionnaire et
qui dit pour autant il va falloir
totalement revisiter la façon dont on
voit notre avenir économique et il va
falloir transpirer un peu et ne pas
rêver en couleur d'un monde dans lequel
tous les problèmes seraient résolus à la
fois en attendant l'exécutif dit non à
cette idée d'impôt est-ce que l'impôt
est une solution non ça c'est Bruno Le
Maire si une taxe suffisait à
transformer notre pays et l'avenir de la
planète ce serait formidable ça c'est
Olivier Véran
financer la transition sans les outils
de la dette et de la fiscalité c'est
impossible bah écoutez si Monsieur le
Maire accordait un peu plus de temps aux
limites physiques au renflement brun et
bien oui oui c'est une citation
littéraire de son dernier livre de son
dernier roman
et bien et bien peut-être qu'il
comprendrait que il suffit pas de dire
non en saoulant par terre pour échapper
un certain nombre d'évolutions qui sont
en cours donc Monsieur le Maire il se
situe toujours dans une optique dans
lequel on va la croissance ne dépend que
nous du reste l'élection au MEDEF c'est
exactement pareil en ce moment l'un des
deux candidats dit avec moi il va la
croissance c'est comme si la croissance
ne dépendait que d'où quand on comprend
ce qui fonde l'économie c'est-à-dire en
fait des flux physiques on comprend que
la croissance ne dépend pas que nous en
fait historiquement elle a dépendu
essentiellement de l'approvisionnement
énergétique donc il est urgent qu'on ait
un plan B sur qu'est-ce qui se passe si
jamais c'est pas comme ça que les choses
évoluent et encore une fois ça ne dépend
pas essentiellement de nous donc je
trouve que il faut se donner le temps de
lire il y a quand même un millier de
pages dans le rapport
pisanimafouz dont la synthèse ne fait
que 150 il faut se donner le temps de
bien les regarder vous vous trouvez très
intéressant ce rapport alors moi je
trouve très intéressant d'avoir fait ce
travail que je n'ai pas encore lu en
totalité je voilà et je pense que ça
mérite une discussion un peu plus
sérieuse
de la main en disant non non parce que
en fait un problème nouveau on va devoir
inventer des remèdes nouveaux une
question sur la croissance précisément
de l'orange standard d'Inter bonjour
vous nous appelez de Niort
on vous écoute simplement une petite
question pour monsieur Jean-Paul ici
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui le réchauffement
climatique n'est pas complètement
antagoniste avec la culture capitaliste
et malheureusement il a déjà un peu
répondu mais par exemple pourquoi ne
pose-t-on pas dans le domaine
construction des panneaux solaires des
récupérateurs d'eau des choses comme ça
que dès le départ pour nous apporter
grand chose et
nous favoriser le référence
merci Laurent pour cette question
Jean-Marc jancovic si vos réponses alors
c'est un vieux débat de savoir si
capitaliste et pression sur
l'environnement c'est des choses qu'on
va ou absence de pression sur
l'environnement plus exactement ce sont
des choses qu'on va arriver à concilier
alors quand on regarde l'histoire on se
rencontre qu'en fait il y a eu des
sociétés qui n'étaient pas organisées de
manière capitaliste qui ont pour autant
été très productiviste et qui ont exercé
une très forte pression sur
l'environnement il y a au moins deux
exemples intéressants à voir en tête
c'est la Chine et c'est l'URSS
alors on me dira que les alternatives au
capitalisme c'est pas uniquement la
Chine et tout à fait vrai oui non mais
on peut très bien imaginer d'autres
choses mais c'est juste que la
présentation de simplement il y a du
capitalisme donc il y a des problèmes
je ne sais pas si le fait de transformer
mon boulanger en fonctionnaire et
quelque chose qui va supprimer des
problèmes voilà je je dis pas que c'est
oui je dis pas que c'est non je pense
que c'est un sujet qui mérite là aussi
qu'on sait la croissance verte ça existe
alors la croissance verte non ça
n'existe pas au sens où quand on fait
croître les flux physiques on a toujours
les inconvénients de la croissance des
flux physiques et par ailleurs les flux
physiques ils peuvent pas croître
indéfiniment sur une planète dont le
diamètre ne varie pas donc à un moment
il y a pas de croissance du tout vers
tout brune et par ailleurs imaginez
qu'on fait croître les flux physiques
sans les inconvénients associés encore
une fois la croissance non c'est quelque
chose qui c'est quelque chose qui
malheureusement ne flotte pas pour
répondre à la question sur la
construction il y a déjà des contraintes
sur la construction il y a maintenant
une norme qui s'appelle la re 20 20 20
qui sur la construction neuve est assez
dure parce que je crois que c'est une
première mondiale du reste parce qu'elle
impose un contenu carbone maximum sur à
la fois les matériaux utilisés pour la
construction et l'énergie de
fonctionnement derrière pour le bâtiment
il y a des obligations sur les bâtiments
existants qui commencent à arriver par
exemple on peut pas remplacer une
chaudière à fioul quand elle tombe en
panne par exemple il y a des obligations
de rénovation etc donc les passoires
thermiques ne peuvent plus être loués
donc le monde n'est pas encore parfait
mais enfin
il y a des choses qui vont dans le bon
sens alors total un mot sur total qui
tenait son assemblée générale vendredi
dernier le groupe a enregistré un
bénéfice record en 2022 de près de 20
milliards d'euros son PDG Patrick
pouyanet a expliqué vouloir maintenir la
production pétrolière dans la prochaine
décennie et pour cela dit-il j'ai besoin
d'investir dans de nouvelles
installations or le GIEC et l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie disent que
pour atteindre la neutralité carbone il
ne faut plus investir dans aucune
nouvelle installation est-ce que vous
est-ce que c'est audible ce que dit
Patrick pouyanet
alors Patrick pouyanet il est là pour
défendre les intérêts de son entreprise
il est pas là pour défendre les intérêts
du monde donc ce qui on peut très bien
de considérer que ce qu'il dit n'est pas
souhaitable en attendant la solution au
problème elle est pas chez lui c'est pas
Patrick pouillané de décider de ce qu'il
faut faire pour l'avenir énergétique
c'est à la collectivité de décider ça
d'une manière générale si on veut
limiter les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre la collectivité doit considérer
que c'est un objectif éthique et ensuite
dans ce cadre-là l'économie prend la
place qu'elle peut occuper alors si on
veut défonciliser qui va le forcer ce
que je veux dire c'est possible s'il
décide de construire de nouvelles
installations la collectivité donc
l'état absolument le gouvernement nous
le gouvernement c'est doux donc voilà
alors si on décide on pourrait très bien
décider par exemple que une entreprise a
ne peut pas dépasser une certaine
quantité de gaz à effet de serre émis y
compris ce qui était mis par les clients
de l'entreprise donc là en l'occurrence
les clients total c'est ceux qui
utilisent le carburant bon on peut le
décider après il faut en assumer les
conséquences alors une bonne partie des
gens qui disent le problème est
uniquement chez Total en fait le
problème n'est pas uniquement chez Total
sinon ça serait simple il est chez qui
il est partout parce que si vous n'avez
pas de pétrole abondant aujourd'hui vous
n'avez pas la grande distribution parce
que vous n'avez pas les camions et les
bateaux vous n'avez pas les voitures
pour les particuliers or voiture
électrique et il y en a quand même pas
beaucoup aujourd'hui vous etc donc je
dis pas qu'il faut pas le faire je dis
juste il faut bien comprendre que en
fait vous pouvez pas extraire juste une
entreprise du système que nous avons
construit en disant celle-là je la
zigouille et le problème est réglé c'est
malheureusement beaucoup plus compliqué
que ça donc je dis pas qu'il faut pas le
faire je dis il faut bien comprendre que
ça n'est que la partie émergée de
l'iceberg et que c'est l'ensemble de la
civilisation que nous avons bâti qui
dépend des combustibles fossiles y
compris la part des emplois dans le
tertiaire et les retraites alors la
première usine de batterie pour voiture
électrique et inaugurée aujourd'hui à
Douvrin dans les Hauts-de-France et une
courte entreprise stellantisme Mercedes
total énergie trois autres entreprises
de batterie de voiture électrique sont
déjà annoncés en France c'est ça ce
qu'il faut faire dans le pays partout en
Europe c'est la naissance d'une nouvelle
filière industrielle alors bien sûr que
oui il va falloir créer des nouvelles
filières industrielles ou les développer
plus exactement et en remplacer d'autres
alors on l'a déjà fait dans le passé
dans le cas de la mondialisation en
France on a fait plus d'avions et moins
de chaussettes donc le remplacement
d'une filière industrielle par une autre
c'est pas quelque chose de nouveau là
dans à l'avenir c'est une très bonne
idée de faire en France des voitures
électriques plutôt que des voitures à
pétrole et c'est une très bonne idée
d'essayer d'intégrer à l'amont le
maximum d'étapes de fabrication parce
que en fait l'assemblage de la batterie
c'est juste la partie finale si je passe
si je prends l'histoire du début il faut
avoir des mines sortir un certain nombre
de métaux des mines alors justement
c'est une question c'est une question de
d'un de nos auditeurs peut-on vraiment
promouvoir les véhicules électriques
c'est Julien qui possède question
lorsqu'on connaît les conditions
d'extraction des matières premières pour
la fabrication des batteries alors quand
on utilise une voiture à pétrole on
extrait aussi des matières premières on
vient d'en parler juste avant on extrait
une matière première qui s'appelle le
pétrole à la fois pour fabriquer la
voiture parce qu'il faut de la chimie
organique et pour la faire avancer on
extrait des minéraux on extrait du fer
en particulier une voiture c'est
essentiellement du fer on extrait et du
cuivre on extrait du sable et du
carbonate de calcium pour faire les
vitres on est donc on a aussi de
l'industrie minière qui est associé à
une voiture fossile il faut pas croire
que il y a que la voiture électrique
là-dedans si on regarde la voiture
électrique il va aussi falloir des mines
absolument de façon il faut des mines
pour n'importe quoi y compris pour faire
le casque que vous allez sur les
oreilles donc vous avez raison mais
puisque puisqu'on parle de des voitures
je voulais juste vous faire réagir sur
ce sondage la consultation lancée par le
Sénat sur la mise en place des des ZFE
vous savez les zones non mais pour
lutter contre la pollution de l'air dans
les grandes
agglomérations on interdit certains
passages et là quand même les chiffres
sont à hurricents en tout cas éditions
86% des particuliers consultés
contre le déploiement de ces zones 83%
des particuliers sont des disent je ne
veux pas changer de voiture et je ne
veux pas de ces zones affaiblissement
qu'est ce que vous en concluez ça ça
rejoint notre toute première question
qui était de vous demander est-ce qu'il
y a un changement des mentalités
donc si on industrialise le pays pour
faire des voitures électriques
l'idéal c'est de faire toutes les
opérations à l'amende de l'assemblage de
la batterie parce que c'est des
opérations très énergivores et c'est
plus intéressant pour l'empreinte
carbone de la batterie de les faire chez
nous avec de l'électricité des carbonées
plutôt que chez les autres avec de
l'électricité plus carbonée et ça joue
sur un facteur 3 sur l'empreinte carbone
de fabrication de la batterie qui
elle-même représente la moitié ou plus
des émissions de la voiture au moment où
on la fabrique la voiture électrique
donc c'est une étape importante et c'est
également une étape importante en ce qui
concerne la valeur ajoutée il vaut mieux
l'avoir chez nous plutôt que de l'avoir
chez vous maintenant pour finir et
répondre à la question sur les de feu je
ne crois pas que nous allons remplacer
dans les délais les 1,2 milliards de
voitures à pétrole qu'il y a dans le
monde par des voitures électriques dans
les 30 ans qui viennent j'y crois pas et
je suis même très perplexe quant au fait
qu'on pourrait remplacer en France les
40 millions de voitures particulières
que nous avons et sur laquelle nous
avons bâti nos habitudes dont les 83% de
gens qui disent qu'ils sont contre par
des voitures électriques de une tonne ou
plus je pense qu'on y arrivera pas donc
il va falloir faire aussi avec moins de
voitures après le débat est ouvert pour
savoir comment on fait avec moins de
voitures les aides c'est une tentative
aussi pour faire avec moins de voitures
et les gens vous répondent je vois pas
comment je vais faire c'est pas c'est
pas très étonnant qui est des gens qui
disent je vois pas comment je vais faire
mais ça n'est que le début de la
discussion Jean-Marc Président c'est la
question que vous pose Jacques
voilà ma réponse ben voilà un grand
éclate merci Jean-Marc Jean-Paul vici
d'avoir été à notre micro il est 8h48